I know that I'm not in a position to say it,
but please,
could you please break up with Masamune-sama?
[Music]
Look up and there's
no reason for me to ask you.
Masamune-sama doesn't love you. His
feelings are different.  I know that even though I'm
tied up with my past thoughts, I'm suffering a lot right
now.I looked at that guy's notebook a while ago.It's all about
revenge, and it's filled with things like how he's
going to conquer the me he hates.
Yes, that's what
happened, but if you knew,
why?
[Music] It's obvious
because it's a tree.
[Music]
At first, I couldn't believe it at all, but I thought they were just calling out to me randomly, pretending to have a good face.
He's a hard-working idiot, isn't he? He doesn't mind working hard like that,
but if he
thinks that I don't like him, he'll panic, and if someone treats me
inappropriately, he
'll get angry. I wonder why he doesn't get upset about it, and I
actually started thinking about it a long time ago.  When I found out it was Masamune, I was so
happy [Music]
[Music]
Ma'am:
Even after we started dating, there were a lot of
things that bothered me, but when I
realized that I don't really like the person I used to be, or the person I am now, it makes
sense sometimes.
Yes, I understand how you feel, Aki-sama.Why do you
love Masamune-sama?I know that in the
past, he was also weird and twisted.Even if he hated me or
denied me, I
can't separate him from him now.  It's
me